O Google não vaibedir, né?
Tá bem.
Vamos lá.
Tu vai se jogar no vlog?
Vou.
Cadê o...
O que ele falou?
O carro.
Cidade de Rado em Rado.
Jogando.
É.
60 Watts.
Pô, não tem mais né?
Que essa que sabe o leite.
Sabe o leite.
Já foi mostrando.
Fui de papo.
Fui de papo por 5 dias.
Moro e equivocado, né?
Deve ser um bocheque aí.
Ficava com a lado, né?
Tudo bem.
Fiquei muito choro, gente.
Obrigado.
Para tirar as fotos e tal.
E que?
Não.
Assim, eu não estou muito perto com essa conta aí, não.
Mas aí por exemplo, ele não me dá as imagens.
Ele não.
É só assim.
Tá.
Ela é do Bandeirão, né?
É.
É do Bandeirão, mas...
Esqueci, né?
O que?
Esqueci agora.
Desligado.
Sim, é.
Aí foi o bando que foi marchado, né?
Ah, deve ter afastado o...
O Grinder
Você tá bem?
Tá triste
Vai se molhar não?